hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the feeder Grand Prix its way with
the white pieces against the opponent
and they are battling it out to see who
will take first place of course but not
only that to see if MVL gets into the
candidates or if Knepper wins the finals
then nipple gets into the candidates and
then mvl is out since the wild-card can
only be a Russian player and if nip well
basically it's between Kirilenko and the
an opponent she and if nipple qualifies
we had a feeder grand prix then Alex
saying who gets the the other candidate
spot for finishing third in the in the
feeder grants which tournament that
we've also covered so that being said
let's check out the game way with the
white pieces opens with night of three
the rate the opening we have Knight to
f6 c4 and c5 we have Knight to c3 Knight
to c6 or the symmetrical and d4c cactus
Knight captures and East six now we have
g3 by ye preparing Tiffin get otherwise
for Bishop and Queen to b6 now putting
pressure on the knight on d4 and now
comes Knight d2 b5 just avoiding any
trades going for the d6 square we have
Knights the e5 and now comes Bishop the
g2 now that the d6 square is nicely
protected so it's not a problem the
shove g2 and a6 now pushing the knight
back Knight the a3 well not right away
but after a six Queen to a four now you
cannot capture because the rook will be
hanging and rook the b8 so this is a
well known line in which nipple goes for
William Knight back to a three and now
Bishop to e7 or even captures on a three
have been played here but neppo goes
Bishop to c5 goes for the f2 pawn and
it's not a problem you don't have to
worry about any Knight a four ideas
since the queen is on a four with
castles now DF two point is nicely
protected and also neppo castles and the
rook to be one now the bishop can be
developed as the b2 pawn is also
protected and here again there are a lot
of moves that have been played here at
d6 has been played here Bishop back the
e7 has been played here at night the c6
has been played here but the move nipple
plays Queen before the early offer of a
queen trade is a new
and it is as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game
so we declines the trade he goes back
Queen back to d1 and now just d6 so it's
a pretty weird setup here but if it
works you know why not
and here nights the a4 perhaps a bit
unprincipled maybe you want to start
developing your other pieces but we he's
there are 2700 a plus player he can
break the principles so tonight the a4
he wants the trade Bishop for a night
and nipple now welcomes it with b5 with
night captures on c5 Queen captures and
C capture Sun b5 with a capture Sun b5
and only now Bishop to g5 developing and
here nipple doesn't mind the doubling of
the pawns he just goes Bishop to a6 now
if he wants to play b4 open up this
diagonal for his light square bishop we
have Knight back to C - yeah I know if
you can get a 3 and B 4 in should be it
should be very nice for white so b4
right away not allowing it also you
don't want to allow something like a
three and knights the b4 could be quite
quite a blockade so opening up the white
square diagonal and now Knights the d4
we have pushed back the b7 now offering
a trade of light square bishop and look
the C one pushing nipples Queen back
Queen to a5 attacking the a to pawn and
here Bishop captures on b7 first with
rook actress and now way captures on f6
he messes up the King's pawn structure
we have G captures on f6 in the now
Queen to b3 defending the a to pawn but
now rook to e8 and here alright
Black's pawn structure is a bit messed
up the material on the board is equal
but it's it's nipple who definitely has
the pressure especially on the a file
and here we have f4 by way pushing the
knight back but before reacting to this
Queen to a7 saying okay you capture I'm
just gonna capture with check and then
pick up the pawn as well so III
defending and and only now tonight back
to d7 and here there really is no good
way of defending da to pawn well unless
you want to move
away from the only open file on the
board and the endangers give black the
open file here we have Queen back to d1
trying to create some chances on the
Kings side and it comes with the price
of one pawn so Queen captures on a to
Queen to g4 with check King h8 and now
Queen to h5 going after the f7 pawn and
now comes King back to g8 here where he
repeats Queen G for checking a trade
Queen to h5 we have King to g8 and here
we is you know not not all that
satisfied with how things turned out and
he doesn't want a draw with the white
pieces already since they basically just
started playing so he decides to go to
go for something more Knight the b5 now
he's threatening the d6 pawn and
everything seems seems to be perfectly
fine seems like he can always repeat if
he wants to but here in Ephesus nope
rook captures on b5 here nipple gives up
the exchange for grabbing yet another
pawn and ok Queen captures on b5 and
then now Queen captures and beaters so
not only are you up to pawns but also
you have a very strong past beep on
which is very unlikely that you'll be
able to keep about the for the moment
you have it
rugby one attacking the Queen and now
Queen the c2 and for the moment that the
pawn is the pawn is off-limits
if you grab it I just rope to a2 and you
are not preventing checkmate here either
irie-kun g2 or Queen to H 2 will be
mated there's no defense against this so
after Luke c2 we have look F the c1
pushing the Queen back and then now rook
to Queen to d2 and now neppo is
threatening to capture on e3 so you
cannot keep harassing the black Queen
and here
well Queen captures and before we decide
stuff eliminate the past pawn but he has
to allow Queen captures on e3 with check
we have King h1 and did not look to a 2
with some nasty threats like Queen to f3
check fall by Queen to g2 mate so you
have to defend we have looked the CH
check first King to g7 and now rook the
b2 just blocking this rook
so what do you do here we have Queen to
f3 check first if you go look they won't
check white just defend so it's not a
problem we have Queen f3 checking g1 and
queen to d1 check came to g1 and now
look the a1 with the idea of Queen to f1
mate
so Queen to b5 defending the f1 square
and now just f5 there's no worry about
Queen captures because the Queen to f1
is still made so we have Queen back to e
2 offering a queen trade and now Queen
d5 check now it's a neighbor who avoids
the Queen trade King back to h3 not back
to h3 I realized I sometimes to say back
to h3 even though the King was never
actually there I don't know why I do it
but I just do so nice to f6 now the
Knight has some ideas of coming to g4
but also to e4 if you will be for
example if you if you place the night
and e4 move the Queen then perhaps you
can start advancing your deep on now but
okay rook beat the b8 now and having a
lot of pressure along the back rank and
here comes Luke the a2 now putting
pressure on the Queen if you move the
Queen away from the defense of the g2
square you don't want to allow something
like Queen g2 so we have looked the c2
again blocking so we've route captures
and c2 Queen captures and C to end Queen
to f3 check with some nice ideas of
hoping to get the King up the board but
it's not going to be easy you if you
could get something like to guard the g2
square for example with the nice and me
like Knight g4 to e3 that'd be great
then the Queen h5 would be made since
the night we'll be covering the g2
square but that's a lot of work so look
the b3 pushing the Queen back not
allowing any sneaky ideas Queen f1 check
Queen blocks Queen g2 and now Queen to
II 1 we have Queen back to b2 and came
to g6 just unpinning so the knight can
move came back to g2 and now it's really
back to G 2 and now d5 we have rook to
b8 and Queen the e4 with check we've
came back to h3 and now Queen to f3 so
again we reach
a similar position only the point has
been advanced but again you don't want
to allow black any moves here so look
back to b3 if you try something like
Queen to b3 that's not not the same it
doesn't work because now if we into f1
you no longer have this and if after
King moves now you just start pushing
your pawn and it's well the Queen
already guards D 3 and D 1
the knife comes to e4 it's gonna be well
it's just over here so look the b3 like
the previous time Queen f1 Czech Queen
again blocks Queen G - Quinta II one
again everything the same Queen to c2
and the Queen to f1 Czech Queen to g2
now Queen back to c4 and rook to b8 so a
way is just saying okay if you want to
try and make progress try and make
progress with h6 a nice pawn move so now
you don't mess up and run into a 50 move
rule and kink the h4 now remarkably but
the King is quite safe there and here is
the moment that nipple should definitely
have gone start pushing the D pawn but
instead he went for Queen to d3 Queen to
d3 is a sneaky move of course you want
to play Queen D 1 on 1 followed by going
to h5 mate now that the king is on h4
but it also allows the white to consult
a chance to consolidate so we look back
to be 2 now if you go to the one you can
always just block with the Queen it's
not a problem since both the rook and
the Queen control the second rank and
then now Knight to g4 again there's
always this opportunity to play d4 but
it's a remarkable how how long nipple
will try everything else until he maybe
pushes it so Quinta e2 again way he
wants the trade we have Queen back to d4
and now King back to h3 it's important
to mention that way he has only four
minutes on the clock and nipple has 18
minutes on the clock but there is
increment so you do get 30 seconds every
time you make a move so it's not that
big of a deal
Queen the g1 by a nipple putting
pressure on h2 although it's not really
that big of a deal since now
well it's very nicely protected but
queen g2 pushing it back Queen to d4 and
now again Queen e2 we have Queen the c5
where you just repeats Queen c2 he says
okay I'm up for a draw never repeats
Queen g1 we have Queen g2 again but now
nepo switches the move order now he
first goes Quinta III a nice
triangulation with the Queen Queen e2
and only now Queen d4 so it's the exact
same position only now it's a wheeze
move so he cannot play whatever he wants
but that usually means that you will
have more chances to make a mistake so
Queen to c2 but now tonight's the e3
attacking the Queen here and already the
night is a very unpleasant piece here we
have Queen to b3 getting the Queen out
of the way and now Knight to d1 with an
attack on the rook and also you have
night to have to check if needed but
also very interesting was Queenie for
because like I said the knight covers
the g2 square something like Queen f3 to
h5 could be made but White has a very
nice defense it's Queen to be 8 and now
if you continue with Queen f3
you get Queen to g8 check and now it's a
draw
king of six you're gonna go Queen hmj
Queen g8 Quinte chat or if you go to h5
then Queen captures and f7 is made so
although it is possible to play with the
Queen e4 to f3 idea well not to f3 idea
about Queenie 4 is possible but you will
have to continue in a different way for
example if Queenie for going to be 8
you're gonna have to go King g7 and
mouth 25 check it trades Queen's which
you know never captures captures you
will prob lack o is of course better but
you know it's hard to say if if black
will be able to push for more than a
half a point
so after Queen to b3 nipple goes for
Knights the d1 instead and now rook the
e2 getting the rook out of harm's way
Knight to F to check and now you can go
for some like King gauge for then Queen
f6 is made
so instead King back to G 2 and now
Knight back to g4 also we reach a very
similar position and now Queen to b8
again with some
Rhett's of Quinta g8 so tonight back to
f6 guarding the g8 square and now Queen
back to be to again we offers a queen
trade Queen back the c5 Roxy two attacks
the Queen and Queen to e3 we have rook
the e2 Queen to a7 and now comes Queen
to a2 we have Queen back to c5 and Queen
to c2 so are we still hoping to get that
draw Queen to b6 now with the ideas of
pushing the pawn and now Queen to be -
and here's the question do you push the
pawn or do you not pull the pond and
it's really it's really interesting what
happens if you push the pawn if you push
the pawn then you get well the question
is can the pawns survive after rook to
d2 it because now it's obviously
attacked twice the point is you have
Queen d5 check King g1 and now after d3
a white will have to play a move and
it's interesting but there's only one
good move for white here and it's Queen
to a 3 with a double attack from the
Queen and a 3 it's incredibly hard to
find as you'll see because here now you
have to go for Queen d4 check King g2
Queen efore check King H 3 and now
Quinta II 1 now you give up your
precious pawn after the Queen captures
that Queen captures and now you play 94
where the rook is under attack and now
there is no defense against well a
knight have to check so once you move
the rook from Howard harms away you
still play a knight after you check now
you have to you have to capture it
otherwise you lose the Queen on d3
it's a very nice fork so real capture
screen captures and you get the same
game where black is up a pawn in a queen
and pawns endgame so this is basically
what you get if you push d4 with perfect
plate from white but neppo plays Knight
e4 he prefers to have his knight on e4
before starting to advance the point but
of course now way he prevents it with
Queen to d4 and now gaining control of
this diagonal it will be very hard for
nipple to push d4 so Quinta a6 attacks
the rook on a honey - we look back the
c2 and now Knight back to f6 so just
going back and forth for now playing on
ways low low time but there is increment
so we not in all that much time trouble
roll back the d2 and now Queen to a5 we
have
- E - and now Quinta a three and here we
place Queen to be - he offers a queen
trade and now Queen back to a seven now
again gaining control of the d4 square
and now Queen a - again way he offers a
trade Queen back to d7 and again Queen
back to be two
and now nepo took this opportunity it's
the exact same position as before only
the queen is on d7 instead of on d6 but
it's really it doesn't really matter in
this case
so here Napo does play d4 so what
happens next is look - D - like we've
shown in the previous line Quinta d5
check that's why I said it was a
completely the same if the Queen was on
d7 or Oren d6 because queen d5 check is
crucial for the line and now comes King
to g1 king h3 not really good after
after d3 the Queen can come here and
it's not not gonna be not going to be
very pleasant or you can go to f3 with
ideas of Queen to f1 and you will not be
able to at the hold of that and the
guard the d3 point at the same time also
the knight is jumping in so after King
to g1 we have d3 and here we have that
moment where I said it's completely the
same as before winter a3 the only good
move but we know with who was now lower
on time I thought he had time to
calculate all of the intricacies that
show up after the D pawn is pushed
played Queen to e5 he offered the
Queen's right here and he wants to go
into into an endgame for example
captures captures Night Moves you
captured the d3 pawn makes sense but it
doesn't work this move actually loses
the game for Wii so feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out why it
loses the game while I give you a couple
of seconds in fact we had three minutes
here so take even 3 minutes if you like
yes so it's fair so for those of you who
were able to do it in 3 minutes or less
or even more our congratulations on
finding the only moves that win the only
move that wins in this complicated
endgame and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it's
efore you offer the Queen trade this way
because now if the Queen's are traded
now you get two connected passed pawns
here and that's of course just winning
and if you don't trade Queens here well
you don't really have a move
well black can just take all the time in
the world and play all the useful moves
he wants he can play Knight d5 - III to
c4 for the Queen and the rook or just
kick away the rook start pushing the d3
pawn if you don't trade you don't have a
move black just wins
so we traded here but now like I said to
connected passed pawns that's that's too
strong King f2 was played we have Knight
to d5 not allowing King III so King back
to e 1 and now King to f5 we've looked a
d1 trying to hold but it's very hard he
5 with King to d2 captures on f4 we have
captures and captures and the now rook
to a1 trying to make use of the rook
from the side King e5 with ideas of just
coming here and starting to push the
pawn we have worked the a6 attacking the
pawn but nipple even protects that one
we looked at a 8 and now f5 and it was
in this position unmoving 96 that we
resigned the game and nepo wins the
first game of the classic which brings
him very close he's almost in the
candidates tournament well I kind of
think he's in the candidates tournament
whether he wins or loses to we because
if it's between him and Kirilenko who
gets the wild-card I really do think
that they'll pick nipple but you know
either way but they're here it's just
too easy for whatever wife plays let's
say you do a few checks check check
check
and the knight blocks next you don't
really have a move next you can just
play f4 III and the pawns just do the
work themselves
so after f5 we resigned and what like I
said nipple is almost in the candidates
turn tournament and MVL is almost not in
the canvas turn but there's still chance
if we wins tomorrow with the black
pieces in a classical game and then
beats
nipple in the tiebreaks then it's MVL
who qualifies via the feeder grand prix
and maple
will most likely get the wild card but I
could be completely wrong I have no idea
if they just flip a coin when they have
two wild cards or is there like a
meeting or maybe a discussion you know
who knows how they do it but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Sanjay shot of
Stefan Miller Daniel drily Trent Lucia
and John Roberts for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
Grand Prix finals continue to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and do be a part of the subscribers
video if you don't know what it is
there's info about it in the description
below so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Saturday